porque se ha hecho esta consulta y que
puede pasar finalmente con la
vicepresidencia se llegó a un acuerdo
para que el segundo candidato más votado
fuera fórmula vicepresidencial ahora
mismo sería francia márquez pero en las
últimas semanas desde el entorno de
petro se ha puesto en duda por posibles
coaliciones que puedan llegar después de
estas elecciones
bueno yo creo que justamente
se lanzaron a una consulta por dos temas
por hacer campaña antes
sino los tiempos para hacer campaña
hubiera sido mucho más corto sería no
presidir una campaña presidencial de
prácticamente dos medios mientras que
con la consulta vemos que van casi que
desde noviembre aunque gustavo petro
lleva en campaña desde el 7 de agosto
del 2018 entonces yo creo que justamente
para no perder esa como ese impacto que
tienen ante la ciudadanía se lanzaron a
hacer una consulta presidencial a masas
por todo el tema de pedagogía electoral
justamente lo que hablábamos antes el
congreso no no estaba caracterizado por
que la gente participe más activamente
en las elecciones mientras que la
pedagogía de votar pactó tres veces le
caló mucho a la gente a la ciudadanía en
las calles sabían que era mucho más
fácil contar tres veces por el logo de
petro que solamente si se hubiera hecho
en las listas de senado y cámara
entonces creo que esa también fue una
estrategia para jalonar las listas y
lograr esas mayorías que estaban
ayudando
gustavo bolívar había anunciado hace
unos meses que su meta era sacar 5
millones de votos tanto en la costa como
en gran distancia senado y cámara y eso
solamente era posible si se hacía el
paquete de las tres votaciones al mismo
entonces yo creo que esa fue la
principal razón por la cual se lanzaron
a una consulta ahora sobre el tema de
vicepresidencia si es cierto que han
habido un poco de rumores frente al tema
del incumplimiento en este caso como
vemos la tendencia de que la
vicepresidencia hacienda deje nada
francia márquez pero creo que sí va a
depender un poco de las otras alianzas
que consolide petro hemos visto cómo
tuvieron un problema en la conformación
de las listas de senado de las cámaras
territoriales al menos sacan bogotá un
lío por las posiciones en las cuales se
ubicaron los candidatos a la cámara se
cumplieron los pactos y justamente con
la lista de francia marcas de eso y por
qué somos entonces creo que
soy de las personas que creen que hay
que esperar a los resultados finales
para ver si se va a cumplir o no lo
creería que no se no se va a cumplir
justamente por estas alianzas que él ha
hecho porque quiere ganar